notre dame de paris portent encore les
traces du violent incendie du 15 avril
dernier les voûtes les pignons et les
murs ont été mis à rude épreuve par les
flammes
l'eau et la chaleur du brasier au coeur
du chantier un robot poursuit son
travail
retirer les débris qui sont
méticuleusement trier et récupéré depuis
le drame
des ouvriers travaillent sans relâche
sur le vieil édifice parisien qui fait
aujourd'hui face à une nouvelle menace
la canicule la canicule m'inquiètent
beaucoup parce que comme vous le savez
la cathédrale a subit donc le feu
l'incendié
le choc des pièces de bois et ensuite il
ya eu le choc de l'eau les pompiers
les températures extrêmes assécherait
trop vite les joints gorgée d'eau depuis
un incendie et ferait courir de nouveau
risque à l'ensemble de la structure
mon envoi c'est que les joueurs ou les
maçonneries à force de sécher perdent
leur cohérence leur cohésion et leur
qualité structurelle et que tout d'un
coup paf la voûte puisse tomber la
semaine dernière le ministre de la
culture était justement venu constater
l'étendue des travaux de rénovation et
de sécurisation en cours
le chantier pourrait durer cinq ans
voire plus ici florence guaino radio
canada montréal